hello and welcome to feed bakula the
show that's all about what you've been
saying this week to my consternation all
you've been saying is flappy bird yes
with a new generation of consoles upon
us the Unreal for engine on the way and
some really interesting stuff happening
with the oculus rift all anyone's been
playing this week is a game where you
tap the screen to make a bird go up and
along between a bunch of pipes at least
you were until the creator of flappy
bird donggu Ian whose name I have almost
certainly mispronounced suddenly pulled
the game from the App Store and Google
Play despite the fact it was apparently
pulling in fifty thousand dollars a day
explaining himself on Twitter he said he
simply couldn't take it anymore though
he was keen to say pulling the game was
nothing related to legal issues in other
words our Creator decided he didn't want
the thing he made to be available
anymore because that's something he has
the right to do the reaction from across
all the internet not just our commenters
was staggering how in the hell did this
dumb game become a hit it's sooo garbage
two people really fall for this crap
seriously oh my god why are you people
talking about this game who gives a fact
about flappy bird who is this guy Phil
fish to stop whining you little girl you
made 50 grand and AD revenue a day
welcome to the internet you know the
same guys that made you earn that money
just ride it seriously that is the
source of that is supposed to determine
consoles he's saying that so more people
try his game and after 24 hours you're
back down that's how disgusting these
people our game should have been pulled
because it sucks I never heard of this
gay but within a day it's all over the
media is this the garbage the media
dishes out to people in a day you are
all such [ __ ] sheep that's a lot of
vitriol right there and I'd like to
remind you it's directed at one dude who
made a game because he likes making
games okay
where you make a bird flap between pipes
possibly the most inoffensive game
concept since perma stoned indie title
Proteus so just why has this simplistic
little time sink ruffled so many
feathers well firstly its popular so
popular people are still trying to buy
it now it's been pulled for example
through troll riddled ebay auctions for
phones with flappy bird installed some
say they're even taking to the streets
all right mate uh you got any flappy
you're cool now right now yeah i got my
favorite is dulled well how much
underground i'll go away y'all right
second flappy bird is hated because it's
not just popular it's casual meaning
it's guaranteed to bring a load of
pretentious told out of the woodwork who
want to save casual gamers from
themselves with their unique brand of
douchery like these guys honestly in a
way we hardcore is just Billy tasteless
than idiotic people who are playing the
game despite it being a condemnable
behavior the medium can only benefit if
we manage to drive away this kind of
people from it mainstreaming of the
gaming hobby after all hasn't brought
many benefits aside from famous actor
voice acting and look at that shooter
realistic explosion this [ __ ] is not a
game it's a king app it's like this
doesn't work the title game oh this is
engine 2 again the most of us would
equate to a minigame in far more
engaging games hanes is amazing what
casuals are so easily amusement thanks
for the analysis yeah douchebags so
ultimately flappy bird proved itself to
be a lot more than just a simple game
about flying between pipes it became a
vast economic success then it became a
target for those people who found it
somehow offensive to their delicate
sensibilities as gamers that the game
exists in the first place if nothing
else flappy bird has shed some light on
a particularly ugly corner of the gaming
community people talk about themselves
as hardcore gamers as if they're an
all-knowing superior class a smarter
more discerning type of player who is
quite happy to be left to their
superlative game experiences when those
casual players they're so keen to
dismiss as irrelevant enjoy something to
the extent it actually gets popular
though all the toys come out the pram
those same aloof hardcore players get
offended because casual players have
found something they like or because it
doesn't align with their lofty
perceptions of what is truly good and
it's that kind of attitude that frankly
pisses me off these people want to have
their cake eat it then tell other people
they're morons for their own choice of
sponge and that's kind of sad really
anyway that's all we got time for this
week I've probably offended about a
third of our viewership so I best lay
low for a bit please direct any personal
insults at johnette until next week when
I shall return
bye